this is see Mei Chao she sleeps just
four to five hours a night I do set an
alarm but I've never really heard it go
off I don't even know what it really
sounds like that's because she might
have a very rare and recently discovered
genetic mutation that makes her what
researchers are now calling natural
short sleepers to learn more about these
genes what they mean for natural short
sleepers and the rest of us who need
twice as much sleep per night I sat down
with the researcher who discovered these
genes
i meanwe foo and I'm a professor of
neurology at the University of
California San Francisco what actually
is the definition of a short sleeper
there are two types of short sleepers
one is we call them habitual short
sleepers there are the people who
probably are not genetically wired but
they somehow train themselves to do
different things so they sleep fewer
hours and then most people and I it's
hard to say what the long-term
consequences will be right but at the
time that we study our we call them
nature short sleepers and their body so
wired to to be short sleepers so our
definition is usually somewhere four to
six hours if they sleep more than what
they need like six or six in half they
actually feel awful
yeah so it's reverse one was right I
would love to sleep ten hours in 2009
you discovered the first gene that was
associated with short sleeping and just
recently you've discovered a second gene
right so recently we published the
second and third mutations they also
cause people to be short sleepers so
these are all genes with different
functions so the biggest question I have
now and also for the sleep field is that
we really don't know very much or
anything at all about how sleep is
regulated especially with the sleep
homeostasis right and so we're kind of
working trying to piece together a
puzzle that we have no idea what's in
the puzzle and right now all we can say
is we have this genes and they encode
four completely different things and we
don't know what they do but hopefully
when we find more we'll be able to
somehow converge them and find
come on pathways that regulate how our
sleep homeostasis works so so once
you've identified a person or a family
who is is experiencing short sleep how
do you actually go about finding the
gene or the mutation responsible for
that so usually we have one person
approaches first and from this person if
we feel this person is a really good
true nature short sleeper we then try to
see if we can recruit this person's
family then we take a little bit of
their plot to get their DNA and use
their DNA to do sequencing and we look
at the entire genome to look for the DNA
changes between them and compared to
normal people or people in the same
family that are not sure sleeper we use
a CRISPR to generate a mice that the
only change they have is the base that
that's the same with human so this mizar
normal completely normal except the
single base that we change according to
the human sure sleeper and so if this
mice who only have one base change also
sleep blasts then the normal mice it
will tell us yes this single base change
is very critical how rare is it how many
people I would guess I would guess one
in several thousand and we have so far
somewhere around 100 just over how many
people good morning it is about 4:30 and
I've been awake for the past 45 minutes
just doing a little bit of reading and
catching up on work emails starting with
people on the East Coast so it seems a
little less crazy in terms of timing
we spoke to CMA who is a short sleeper
do you have any idea what her mutation
is or what's going on with her for she
may we have a dumb question nail and the
interviews strict interview and we feel
that she is true nature show sleeper but
we have not found her mutation yet
yeah so for most of us who are not short
sleepers if we tried to sleep just for
six hours a night we wouldn't suffer
consequences of sleep deprivation and
that's pretty serious stuff right are
these people experiencing any kinds of
abnormalities or other health effects
from sleeping less I cannot say
100-person definitely there is no
negative consequences all I can say is
from our observations so far it doesn't
seem like they have any health problem
and a lot of them lived here 80's and
90's or be young and it's and then there
are some very interesting traits the
hair they have again it's not like a
hundred person of them all have this
traits but a lot of them are very
optimistic and very energetic you know
they sleep few hours their nose but they
have two jobs or three jobs or go to
school for time and have two jobs at the
same time and very good multitaskers and
so and then they also have higher pain
threshold they don't feel pain as easy
as we do and they also don't experience
jet lag a lot of them to experience chat
like another thing very common they say
is a very good memory
they speak many languages or they you
know they're unusual audio memory they
hear something they never forget but
it's just memory seems to be something
that that's very common the American
memory that sounds amazing
do you think that there is something we
can learn about sleep for the rest of
the population for people who need eight
hours of sleep our body is not doing
nothing
you know our body is working very hard
doing things for us so that we can stay
healthy
whatever it takes our body eight hours
to accomplish for these short sleepers
only take four to six hours in other
words their sleep it's more efficient it
means that if we are well rested we are
likely to be like that and there's a lot
of scientific publication now saying
that if we sleep deprived ourselves just
a few hours a day on a long-term basis
the chance for us to have many of the
common diseases is much higher then if
we just sleep we don't get good night's
sleep so short sleepers are
optimistic they have better memory
they're healthier they're living long
lives this seems amazing do you see this
as a sort of human evolution so it
appears I give a it's not a negative
mutations or these are not negative
mutations and why do we only see so few
people among the population and the one
reason I can think of is that these are
probably newer mutations and so because
if you think of our human recent human
history right there are two major events
really significantly changed in our
silly behavior one is the invention of
electricity and light right before
electricity and light we all had to go
to bed soon after dark there was not
much to do right there was no advantage
to stay up late because you you'll be
staying inside and had nothing to do
twist your thumbs right and so there was
no advantage to be sure sleeper in the
second second major event I think it's a
digital revolution that really affects
our sleep so I think that these are all
newer mutations that happen in the maybe
last you know 80 hundred years and
that's why so few people have this
mutations yeah we are barreling toward
an age where people are talking about
things like CRISPR and other techniques
to change our genetics you know in a
world where CRISPR is prevalent do you
imagine this is something that people
could change about their own DNA to me
that day is still far away we first have
to know CRISPR is safe for human because
by changing one gene usually one gene
and one protein they have so many
functions the important thing is you
don't want it to affect other systems
right and so on a shorter term may be
more likely is we can find something
that can help us regulate the pathway
and so that we can sleep more efficient
so I'm not a short sleeper I definitely
need eight hours of sleep a night do you
think that's what you recommend to
people you sleep
for eight hours so when I think most
people majority of the people do need
eight to eight and half hours of sleep
for most people but sleep is really a
very individual thing everybody has
their special sleep pattern well thank
you so much for joining us doc okay
thank you thank you to have me
[Music]